ich finde das ganze statement wahnsinnig
weichgespült und hätte mir was anderes
gewünscht ich hätte mir gewünscht dass
sie ganz klar stellung bezieht und ganz
klar sagt ich distanziere mich von den
aussagen meines mannes und ich bin nicht
seiner meinung das tut sie nicht
stattdessen spur wird sie irgendwas von
wegen sie sei die schweiz und sie wäre
ja auch nicht politisch und redet schon
fast so als wären die beiden seit 30
jahren verheiratet ja wie in jeder ehe
ist es ja so jeder darf jeder seine
eigene meinung haben
das ist mir wirklich zu weichgespült ich
hätte mir da eine starke stärkere
distanzierung gewünscht was ich finde
aber was man sieht ist dass laura
wahnsinnig nervös ist die ist nicht so
locker wie sonst normalerweise redet die
ohne punkt und ohne komma mich sehr
angespannt sehr neutral wie du ja auch
schon gesagt hast und man sieht auch
wenn man genau hinguckt dass das video
zusammengeschnitten ist das ist nicht
ein durchgängiges statement von ihr
sondern da wurden sachen raus
geschnitten und da stelle ich mir
natürlich die frage wer hat da was raus
geschnitten und welchen einfluss hatte
vielleicht auch michael wendler auf
dieses statement von laura ja du sagst
gerade rausgeschnitten außerdem mich
sehr viel inhalt in der ganzen aussage
dafür dass es jetzt tage gedauert hat
bis sie sich geäußert hat hätte man
damit gerechnet dass da etwas etwas mehr
sozusagen bei rumkommt aber wie
dramatisch wäre das jetzt auch noch für
den wendler wenn seine eigene frau
gesagt hätte das was mein mann erzählte
schwachsinn
das wäre vielleicht für die beziehung
der beiden dramatisch gewesen denn
natürlich stellt so was eine wahnsinnige
belastung da es ist natürlich klar dass
wenn wenn der mann so durchdreht und
seine ehefrau mit in den ruin treibt das
tut er ganz klar das muss man so sagen
dann ist das schon mal per se eine
belastungsprobe für so eine sehr junge
beziehung und auch eine sehr junge ehe
aber für die geschäftskunden und für
lauras eigene karriere wäre es besser
gewesen wenn sie sich wirklich klar
distanziert hätte nun kann ich aber dazu
auch nur sagen was erwartet man dann von
einer 20 jährigen die mit einem ende 40
jährigen zusammen ist
sich dagegen aufzubäumen und auch die
das rückgrat zu haben wenn man
vielleicht kein soziales umfeld hat was
einen da gerade auch bestärkt
das ist dann wahrscheinlich auch
wirklich wirklich schwierig ja jetzt
kommen wir tatsächlich noch zu einem
anderen thema aber auch beim wendler
denn das ist neuer beziehungsweise
eigentlich alter ärger für den wendler
dem schlager droht jetzt ein haftbefehl
hier in deutschland er ist ja gerade
selber in den usa warum genau das ganze
muss der wendler jetzt im knast wenn das
nächste mal her kommt also der wendler
hat ja seit jahren probleme mit der
deutschen justiz er hatte eine firma
zusammen mit seiner frau die lief auch
auf seiner auf den namen seiner ex frau
er war dort angestellt die firma es
irgendwann pleite gegangen und nun wird
ihm beihilfe zur insolvenzverschleppung
vorgeworfen bereits im februar wurde er
zu sechs monaten auf bewährung
verurteilt das urteil ist aber nicht
rechtskräftig weil er einspruch erhoben
hat den ersten terminen den ersten
prozesstermin hat er verschoben den
zweiten der eigentlich heute hätte in
dinslaken stattfinden sollen
hat er auch vorzeitig abgesagt mit der
begründung er würde dafür dsds drehen
nun ist dann natürlich kann man sich
natürlich fragen ist das wirklich die
begründung oder hat er vielleicht
sowieso nie vor dazu erscheinen da hat
ja auch großartig angekündigt er würde
nie wieder zurück nach deutschland
kommen fakt ist er darf es gibt einen
neuen termin und die sind davon nicht
nochmal versäumen denn dann droht ihm
tatsächlich hat es gibt drei
möglichkeiten entweder der richter sagt
einfach okay wenn er nicht erscheint
dann ist das urteil rechtskräftig und
erst ein verurteilter straftäter die
zweite variante wäre wäre haft
vorführung das bedeutet die polizei
müsste wenn dann zur verhandlung abholen
aber wie soll das gehen wenn er in
amerika ist also das geht gar nicht und
die dritte möglichkeit wäre und die
härteste möglichkeit es wird ein
haftbefehl erlassen und wenn er dann das
nächste mal in deutschland einreist dann
wird er festgenommen um so lange hinter
gittern bleiben bis der haupt die
hauptverhandlung stattfindet alles im
allen keine besonders rosigen aussichten
für den wendler und
wird ganz klar so als würde er vor der
deutschen justiz fliehen
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren